hey dr berg here i want to explain
vitamin c
normally comes
in a complex in nature it always comes
with a bunch of associated parts so
let's talk about the parts vitamin c
comes from an antioxidant portion right
here or or a protective coating called
ascorbic
acid
and when you go to the store and buy
vitamin c you're normally going to see
ascorbic acid in very high doses dosages
including up to even grams in nature
ascorbic acid never never occurs more
than a hundred milligrams so when you
see vitamin c
tablets over a hundred milligrams
chances are it's made synthetically now
where they make vitamin c synthetically
is from corn starch and sulfuric acid so
they mix those two together and make
this ascorbic acid and tell you it's
vitamin c when it's really a synthesized
version of one part of the vitamin c
complex
so i don't recommend it because there
are side effects in fact when you take
too much
of this one part right here ascorbic
acid you will create deficiencies
in the other parts of the vitamin that
normally come
in nature's package
okay so let me let me just kind of give
you an example i had a patient went to
mexico and went to some of this
alternative clinic to get rid of his
cancer
and they injected him with a hundred
thousand milligrams of ascorbic acid
well he came back with the worst vitamin
c deficiency you've ever seen in your
life
so he had spider veins he had
hemorrhoids he was completely tired so
vitamin c deficiency is basically scurvy
scurvy is fatigue your joints fall apart
and you have a lot of vein
spider vein issues or varicose vein
issues
so
in the vitamin c complex normally in
nature you have vitamin p that's the
bioflavonoids okay that would be the the
factors that support the connective
tissue around the arteries and the veins
that prevent the spider veins on your
nose vitamin j that's the that's the
lung or anti-pneumonia vitamin
and that vitamin helps protect again
going upstairs and preventing you from
getting out of breath easily it kind of
helps your lungs increase oxygen and you
see a deficiency in this in a lot of
asthma cases but it's really just the
vitamin c
complex and then you have copper each
vitamin complex comes with a different
mineral so copper is one of the minerals
in the vitamin c complex but it's
actually in an enzyme form it's called
tyrosinase and tyrosinase is there to
help as a precursor to build the adrenal
hormones and that's why i'm talking
about vitamin c because it's essential
and to build your your adrenal hormones
the reservoir vitamin c in your body is
held in the adrenals
and so we want to make sure that we
don't burn them out by taking too much
ascorbic acid so if you're taking
vitamin c now go get the bottle and just
make sure it doesn't have large amounts
of ascorbic acid you want to get a
natural vitamin c that has low
ascorbic acid and high other factors
through here now we know about vitamin k
that's like the clotting factors and so
people might get bruising if they're
deficient in vitamin k but this is the
anti-pneumonia vitamin this is the
bioflavonoids that support the veins and
without this you get spider veins and
then this is the one that supports the
adrenal
and then ascorbic acid really the only
function of that is to protect
these vital internal parts of the
vitamin c complex this is not the active
ingredient in vitamin c like most people
think and the reason why it works maybe
for when you get sick you might take
vitamin c is the acidifying effect it's
really the acid in the ascorbic acid
that helps kill the microbes of the
bacteria you'd be much better off
consuming apple cider vinegar in water
than you would be ascorbic acid because
ascorbic acid will start depleting you
over the other factors
so when i ask people um you know what
was your history what did you do a lot
of and if they had a lot of
grams of vitamin c or so-called vitamin
c
and they end up with adrenal issues it
could be one
causation of that okay so i just wanted
to mention this just make sure
that your vitamin c comes from a natural
source so you read the label and you
want to see the foods that it comes from
not just a little pinch of
rose hips you want to see that it's low
ascorbic acid and it comes from
foods vegetables and things like that so
one of the top three foods with vitamin
c
are kiwis papaya
and peppers any type of peppers bell
peppers green peppers hot peppers those
are the three foods that have the most
vitamin c on the planet okay
so i hope that helped i will see you in
the next video